-Steve Bannon, the former
chief strategist
to President Trump,
turned himself in
to federal authorities today
after being indicted for defying
a congressional subpoena.
Trump himself, meanwhile,
defended the violent mob
that chanted "Hang Mike Pence"
during the insurrection
on January 6th.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Just to get you guys
up to speed,
you remember Steve Bannon,
the former chief strategist
to President Trump,
who looks like
his morning beauty routine is
to take a peek
inside the Ark of the Covenant.
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
I know,
when I reference that scene,
that most people think
of the guy whose face melted,
but let's not forget
a dude's head also exploded.
[ Laughter ]
That dude doesn't get
enough recognition.
Probably because his
head exploded.
[ Laughter ]
I bet, when he goes
to conventions, now,
to sign autographs, he's like,
"It's me, Head Explosion Guy
from 'Raiders of the Lost Ark,'"
and people are like,
"Sorry, we don't recognize you
with a head."
[ Laughter ]
And he's like,
"Damn you, George Lucas
and your fantastic
special effects team!"
[ Laughter ]
I'm just kidding.
That guy's name is Paul Freeman
and he's outstanding.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Boy, we got to --
we got to start tying
our tangents in
to the rest of the show.
[ Laughter ]
I'll land the next one.
Bannon's already been arrested
once before.
It was last year,
during Trump's presidency,
and he was arrested
by Postal Service inspectors
aboard a Chinese
billionaire's yacht,
for allegedly scamming
Trump supporters
who donated
to a crowdfunding scheme
to buy Trump's wall,
or as they call that,
in the law enforcement
community, a Code 6.
-Steve Bannon
and three other men
have been arrested
and indicted and charged
in relation to their role
in a nonprofit organization
called We Build the Wall.
What the indictment here
is alleging is
that Bannon and these others
were skimming some
of the proceeds from that
fundraising for themselves.
-The court documents
basically say
that this thing was
pretty suspect,
almost from the beginning.
-Yeah, I would say so.
The only way it could've been
more obviously a scam is
if people who donated
were offered
an extended car warranty
and fake boner pills for life.
[ Laughter ]
So, Bannon was arrested
for scamming Trump's
own supporters,
but then, Trump pardoned him
at the last minute
and Bannon made
this mysterious prediction
the day before the
January 6th insurrection.
-It's not going to happen
like you think it's going
to happen, okay?
It's going to be quite
extraordinarily different.
And all I can say is strap in.
The "War Room" posse,
you have made this happen
and, tomorrow, it's game day,
so strap in.
All hell is going
to break loose tomorrow.
Just understand this.
All hell is going
to break loose tomorrow.
-And I'm no detective,
but it sounds like
he knew something was up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like if Nicole Kidman
had found a text
on Hugh Grant's phone saying...
[ Laughter ]
And, if you haven't seen
"The Undoing" yet,
I didn't necessarily
just spoil it.
You don't know
what he did with the hammer.
Maybe he built
his mistress a house.
Spoiler alert --
he didn't build her a house.
[ Laughter ]
Besides, you don't watch
"The Undoing" for the mystery.
You watch it for the scarves.
Nicole Kidman layers scarves
the way Bannon layers
collared shirts.
[ Laughter ]
And will you look at that?
We have landed the tangent.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I mean, I think it almost --
I think, technically,
it counts as a segue way now.
[ Laughter ]
So, naturally, the congressional
committee investigating
the January 6th insurrection
wanted to talk to Bannon,
but he defied the subpoena,
at Trump's request;
Congress held him in contempt;
a grand jury indicted him;
and today, he turned himself in,
although, this time,
it was much less glamorous
than getting arrested
on a billionaire's yacht.
-Trump ally former White House
advisor Steve Bannon.
He is expected to surrender
to authorities
after being indicted
on two counts
of contempt of Congress,
this for defying requests
from the January 6th Committee,
for testimony and documents.
Defying subpoenas.
You're looking at live pictures
of Bannon's home right now.
-Got to say,
Bannon's house looks
a lot more normal
than I was expecting.
I thought I was going to be
a little more like a burrow
[ Laughter and applause ]
or a volcano
in the shape of a skull,
or he'd layer them,
like his shirts,
and it would be a house
inside a second,
[ Laughter and applause ]
slightly larger, house.
I also know
we just made that joke.
So, Bannon's house
looks normal on the outside,
although, I bet you
it's much weirder inside.
It's like when you finally meet
a neighbor who keeps to himself
and you think,
"He must just be a quiet guy,"
and then, you go inside
and his sink
is filled with old newspapers,
his fridge is stuffed
with takeout containers,
and the shelves are filled
with antique ceramic pigs.
Also, your neighbor is
Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Giuliani ]
You want some mayo?
I scraped off the mold.
It's mostly jar now.
[ Laughter ]
And then, when Bannon
finally showed up
at the courthouse this morning
to turn himself in,
he, of course, couldn't help but
shout some incomprehensible,
anti-government babble
into a camera.
-We're taking down
the Biden regime.
Every day, the focus.
You got Raheem Kassam today,
you got Dr. Peter Navarro,
Captain Bannon.
You're going to have
Boris Epshteyn.
The whole show, intense.
We got polling out,
economic data out -- everything.
I want you guys to stay focused,
stay on message.
Remember -- signal, not noise.
This is all noise.
That's signal.
-Wait, I'm sorry. You call
yourself Captain Bannon now?
[ Laughter ]
It's like an ironic nickname
they give the guy
who rinses out the chum buckets
down at the marina.
[ Hoarsely ] Hurry up
with those buckets, Bannon,
we got barnacles to scrape.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, excuse me, Captain Bannon.
[ Laughter ]
Also, it really undercuts
your attempted defiance
and bravado
when there's a guy
right behind you
holding up a sign that says...
[ Laughter ]
Got to be a bummer
for a guy like Bannon,
who thinks he's
an evil mastermind,
to get upstaged by a sign
that clearly took
five minutes to make.
Or, one of Bannon's neighbors
made it months ago,
just in case.
"Oh, what's that for, honey?"
Oh, I don't know.
I just feel like
we might need it, one day.
[ Laughter ]
Bannon definitely likes to think
of himself as a Logan Roy type,
but he's more like
a coked-up flunky
who'd get hired to help
Cousin Greg shred some documents
[ Laughter ]
and accidentally screw it up.
[ As Greg ]
Um, I'm pretty sure
that, uh, Tom told us
not to peruse any
of the confidential materials,
or, in his words,
I'd have to, uh,
"Eat a thousand [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
This is just one step
in the process of holding Trump
and his cronies accountable
for their assault on democracy,
and it's absolutely necessary
because Bannon's not alone.
Virtually the entire
institutional Republican Party
has made it clear
they remain fully devoted
to Donald Trump
and his ongoing attempt
to unravel
our constitutional order.
And I'm not just talking
about the obvious crazies --
the Matt Gaetzes,
Marjorie Taylor Greenes,
Paul Gosars, and Louie Gohmert
of the world.
Or, as Gaetz called them,
last week...
-The Killer G's.
We've heard of the killer bees,
[ Laughter ]
but now, it's Greene, Gosar,
Gaetz, Good, Gohmert.
-The Killer G's
is a good name for that group,
as, every time you remember
they're elected officials,
your reaction is,
"Kill me" or "Jes...us!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, you'd think, if you had,
within the last 12 months,
helped foment
a violent insurrection
where rioters actually chanted
they wanted to kill
the vice president,
you wouldn't go
by the Killer G's.
It's just a little
too on the nose.
[ Laughter ]
It's like if we found out
The New York Times Spelling Bee
was designed
by the Zodiac Killer,
which wouldn't surprise me.
[ Laughter ]
Only a seriously twisted mind
could come up
with such an elaborate form
of psychological torture.
Yesterday,
I spent the entire day trying
to find every last word
in the puzzle
and, when my kids asked me
what they could do
to get me to make them dinner,
I said,
"Find me a word that uses
all seven of these letters!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Because the center one
is a real...
-Killer G.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, seriously,
the Killer G's is one of the
dumbest names I've ever heard.
Did you steal it from a senior
citizens' bowling team?
[ Laughter ]
That's a cute name, Grandpa.
Where'd you come up with it?
"Well, the "G" stands
for Grandpa
and the Killer, well,
let's just say
I did some things in my youth
that I'm not too proud of."
[ Laughter ]
Times were tough back then
and we had to survive.
I got involved in things
I don't understand --
gambling, crime, drugs.
I'm talking cocaine,
methamphetamine, heroin.
[ Laughter ]
Once you ride the black dragon,
there's no telling
what you'll do.
[ Laughter ]
I...choked a man
for a pint of gin.
[ Laughter ]
He was a drifter.
Saw the life drain
out of his eyes.
His body went limp in my hands.
[ Laughter ]
Buried the body
in the Pine Barrens.
I left -- I left so many clues!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Technically, it's a pangram.
But it's not just
the so-called Killer G's
who have fully bought into Trump
and the GOP's ongoing coup.
For example, last week,
ABC released audio
of an interview in which
Trump defended the violent mob
that stormed the Capitol
and chanted, "Hang Mike Pence"
after Pence declined to overturn
the election results.
The most shocking thing
about that clip is,
when I heard it,
my reaction was,
"Alright, that tracks."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it checks pretty much
every Trump box --
"I wasn't worried
about another person's safety.
They kind of deserved it.
Also, did I mention
that I won the election?"
I mean, at this point,
the only way I'm clicking
on a link to Trump audio is
if the headline reads...
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
I [bleep] up, Sean.
I [bleep] up bad and I --
[ Laughter ]
I put my friend's life at risk.
Dear Mike, sweet Mike.
[ Laughter ]
I hope he can --
I hope he can forgive me
and, if he doesn't,
I wouldn't blame him
for a second.
The worst part, Sean,
I knew I lost that election.
I couldn't admit it.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know why --
I think it's dad stuff, Sean,
[ Laughter ]
and, if I'm being honest
with myself,
until I deal with the dad stuff,
I'm not going to be
the best version of myself.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's like Melania says
to me every day...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, you'd think any sane human
being would desperately want
to disassociate themselves
from that, and yet,
when he was asked
about Trump's comment on Sunday,
Wyoming Senator John Barrasso,
by no means considered one
of the Killer G's --
I mean, he'd have to change
his name to Garrasso --
but, still, repeatedly,
he refused to criticize Trump
for defending the mob's call
to "Hang Mike Pence."
-Can your party tolerate
a leader
who defends murderers' chants
against his own vice president?
-Well, let me just say
the Republican Party
is incredibly united right now.
-So you have no problem
with the president saying
"Hang, Mike Pence"
is "common sense"?
-I was with Mike Pence
in the Senate chamber
during January 6th
and what happened was
they quickly got
Vice President Pence
out of there.
I didn't hear any
of those chants.
-Well, we just played
the chants.
I'm asking if you believe,
if you can tolerate
the president saying
"Hang Mike Pence"
is "common sense."
-It's not common sense.
There are issues
of every election.
-But you're not going
to criticize President Trump
for those views?
-I don't agree with
President Trump on everything.
-[ As Barrasso ]
Look, George, the
Republican Party is a big tent.
We don't agree on everything.
Some of us are pro-war.
Some of us are anti-war.
Some of us are pro-vaccine.
Some of us are anti-vaccine.
Some of us want
to hang Mike Pence.
Some of us don't hear when those
people chant, "Hang Mike Pence."
[ Laughter ]
It's called inclusivity.
But that's the reality --
as much as we like
to write it off
as a fringe movement, it's not.
It's the heart
of the modern GOP.
Virtually the entire
institutional Republican Party,
from the so-called Killer G's
to the John Barrassos
of the world,
have apparently decided that
their ticket back to power is
an alliance with Trump
and a guy who looks like
he was stung by a swarm of...
-Killer bees.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.